Speaker 1: Now, I wouldn't normally do this
to you, but it is particularly relevant
based on what's happened over the last week and
the shootings. The day after speaking at the NRA
in Houston, Texas, and dancing on
stage at the end of his speech,
Donald Trump flew to Wyoming and gave a campaign
speech in Wyoming for the Republican challenger
to Liz Cheney. Liz Cheney, now for the MAGA cult
is an enemy because she acknowledges that Donald
Trump really lost the election. They want to
remove her, their primaries, her. She's doing
very well in the polls. She'll probably win. But
Trump flying up there to campaign for. It's funny,
when Trump campaigns for someone, that person
is almost completely irrelevant. I don't even
remember the woman's name. I think it's Ed Hagaman
or something like that. And this Trump's brain
appeared to just break it. His brain is broken.
It's not functioning. In this clip, Trump explains
how his fee tweet I call it Cobb Fee was so big,
he's like bragging about the fact that a tweet
that was literal nonsense and unintelligible
by a president which has never been explained.
He's bragging how it was his most popular tweet
ever. This the guy's brain is not functioning.
Speaker 4: I put out like this tweet. I think it
was like a Saturday morning. And I saw something.
Speaker 1: That.
Speaker 4: Day and I said,
I believe Obama spied on my campaign. Okay? Now,
I didn't think it was that big a deal. You know,
you put it ahead about 3 minutes later, I get
a call like my phone goes crazy. Sir, sir,
did you just say that President Obama spied
on your campaign? Yeah. What's the big deal,
sir? The wires are burning up. I said
room after coffee. It was the single
biggest tweet I ever did. Coffee was bigger.
Speaker 1: But he's ignoring the fact that
the reason it was big is because it was a red
flag globally, that the president has lost his
marbles and his brain is broken after coffee.
Speaker 4: Which was world's number one.
It was the biggest tweet I ever did. And I
thought it was just going to be like routine,
you know, I'm throwing it out. But that's what
I thought. That's what I heard. And you know why
it was such a big deal? Because we caught
them and they realized that we caught them
and it became a monster.
Speaker 1: Now understand that
Obama was not caught spying on Trump's campaign.
None of this makes any sense, but Trump is now
bragging about coffee. This is not a functioning
brain. It's not a functioning brain. Trump then
says that the way to stop the war in Ukraine is to
take out the windmills. Now he means wind farms.
He uses the term windmills. He also wrongly claims
the Russian ruble is now at an all time high.
Speaker 4: That is their doing. And as much as
they're spending, the ruble is at an all time
high because they're taking. In in so much
money. Why want to stop the war? Drive down
the price of oil, drive down the price of energy?
You want to stop and stop with the windmills that
kill all your birds and destroy your environment?
Speaker 1: Yeah, they're called wind farms. And
they don't destroy the environment and
they kill fewer birds than the oil and
gas industry. But more importantly, Trump
says, the ruble is at an all time high.
The ruble is actually close to an all time
low. We're putting the price chart up on the
screen. And as you can see, the ruble is actually
very low now. Revisionist history. Donald Trump
is now calling it a so-called insurrection and he
is saying the idea that it was an insurrection on
January 6th is as fake as the Russia probe,
which, by the way, was very, very real.
Revisionist history and the crowd accepts it.
Speaker 4: Now you look at the so-called word
insurrection, January six. What a lot of crap.
What a lot of. And most of this country knows
it. And you know who else knows it?
The Democrats. It's another con job,
just like Russia, Russia, Russia. This was
made up by Hillary Clinton and the Democrats,
a total fake story.
Speaker 1: Now, I don't know if he's saying
there that the Russia story was fake or that the
insurrection story is fake and made up by Hillary
Clinton. He thinks both are fake for sure. And
then bringing out all of the greatest hits. Trump
also lying about the price of gas.
Speaker 4: $0.87
per gallon gasoline. Think of that now.
It's going to close to $9 today. That's 87.
Speaker 1: $9. And of course, all you have
to do is look at the official gas prices and
you see that when Trump left office,
it wasn't a dollar 87, it was $2.42,
and now it's $4.21. It's much higher. No
doubt nobody denies that it is not $9.
So another absolutely despicable event.
Just a little bonus clip here. Trump
struggling to pronounce the word conservative.
Speaker 4: We're going to vote out this atrocious
rhino and we're going to replace her with a
conservative warrior from a place called Wyoming.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it doesn't seem as though that's
going to happen. Liz Cheney is doing quite well.
I have I'm not a fan of Liz Cheney's. I'm just
telling you what it looks like. It looks like
this will almost certainly be another loss
in Donald Trump's endorsement record. The
man's brain is broken, my friends. And we'll have
these clips on our Instagram at David Pakman show.